new renderings released of the Formula
One experience coming to Las Vegas so
here's a full look at them this is
coming from the F1 Las Vegas Facebook
page wow look at that an unforgettable
race cutting right through the neon
Heart of the City the race set for
November 16th through the 18th more
tickets for the Las Vegas Grand Prix are
headed your way later this month they're
going to go on sale Friday March 24th at
10 A.M American Express card member is
going to get a pre-sale access the 20th
through the 22nd the cheapest ticket
however it's still 500 for general
admission for more information you can
find it on our website just gone to
eightnewsnow.com